is were represented by the um
candidates running for single seed
constituent
so five
parliamentary parties and three
parties um
a total of eight were participating in
the election
well the united part uh the united
russia party had the most of votes
nonetheless it was
it got a little less votes than last
time in 2016.
as for the
[Music]
voting for governors in nine territories
which took place over the same days
right
you can see on the screen
the um single seat constituency
statistics
could you please show us the statistics
for the governor elections
um
which took place in the nine regions of
russia so six out of those
the winners are from the united russia
there's one
independent candidate one candidate from
liberal democrats
and in lyanos
we have a governor from
well we can say almost but
very close to be announced to winner
from the communist party of russian
federation in tulare
region we have an independent candidate
winning
[Music]
and
in
[Music]
is winning from united russia
in mordovia
our term zoom off
uh also from the united russia
in chechnya ramzan kadyrov is also
winning i'm not going to go through the
entire list
uh there's also a candidate winning from
literal liberal democrats
in panzer region oleg melichanga from
the united russia
in
the region also the united russia
that's about it
and on september 19th
three republics there was a vote for the
head of the republic to be elected
so we have
two winners
continue
i would like
to um
ask my colleagues in the regions
please take your time counting the votes
the final vote
uh because it's mo it's important it's
crucial
for us in the central election committee
that you uh take into account all the
complaints if there are any
and
uh deal with them and if there are any
violations or any doubts about
transparency of the election
you need to cancel
the
vote outcome for those constituencies
where you get such reports and they are
verified because this is about our
reputation this needs to be done if you
don't do that and central election could
get complaints about violations we'll
have to cancel it for you but we hope
that you can make these decisions at
your level and you can make it
officially so unless you deal with
all the complaints
um
please do not produce the final official
account we are giving you time
by friday
we are scheduling currently the final
count for friday i hope you have enough
time to do that
this is about our reputation and we want
this election to be clean
um well i would like to say
that we have some information that there
were some ballots
that were cancelled
in 35 regions of russia
[Music]
and krasnoyarsky cry primorsky cry
and so on
regions as well as in moscow and in
moscow region so in all of these 35
regions
out of 85
in
out of over a hundred and thousand um
voting stations
we have a total of twenty five thousand
eight hundred
and 30 illegal votes
the ballots that were cancelled
well um you know in the scale of the
number of votes in the country
this is not a great percentage but we
take it seriously
we hope
that
uh again i would like to repeat my
appeal if you get any complaints
about um
some violations please do it address it
cancel the ballots if necessary
then
as for the canceled
elections
i'm waiting still for the data from
saint petersburg
hopefully
they were working last night
in a number of election stations i know
for sure about one
there will be a cancellation uh and
there will be a criminal
procedure we
called up the police to address that
officially
i think there were some stations
where some meddling
was
with the voting and
therefore the election results at that
station
will have to be canceled we were trying
to do our best to minimize such
possibility but that's what we have and
i'm waiting for the data from saint
petersburg
um well about this
polling station
and all the others if any
[Music]
based on the data we have as of now in
three territories including crimea saint
petersburg
and caracao
[Music]
because of multiple violations
in three stations
there were cancellations as for the
election
[Music]
and in petersburg
the outcome of the election was
cancelled
in three
constituencies
we are going to monitor
all the updates we will be getting
updates every hour
we have managed to set up a most
transparent system make that make sure
that no violation um can be
[Music]
overseen
we have a huge number of observers
they've been working at all the
voting stations and we can see compared
to the previous election we have
a lot less violations registered and a
lot less than ever before
and
if any violation take place
they are reported immediately and we all
will address all of them
that's important to us
all of them will be addressed and we
will act firmly because we want to
we want this
not to repeat again
and
well
the fact that we have a lot of observers
many more than last time is another
guarantee for transparency of the
election we we also had
uh observers from uh different parties
and also from this single city
constituencies
[Music]
000 people and 61.
those
that's the number of observers that were
designated by the parties
with uh
an advisory uh vote
and a total of over 300 000 observers
so in total
there were over 400 000 observers
i'm looking at the statistics now
doesn't seem right to me can you put it
together
so three hundred and four thousand
and 127.
and
and fifty seven thousand and sixty one
that gives us a total of observers
that's 491 000
that's what we have i think i can
calculate correctly that's good yes
so
almost 500 000 of
observers
this is
of people who were really observing at
every single polling station across the
country um
that
includes uh observers from the political
parties and observers from the single c
constituencies as well as observers from
the civic organizations and
non-governmental organizations as well
as the observers with an advisory vote
and in total
we had
reporters
and representatives of
2144 media outlets both from russia and
international broadcasters
no rights were violated including the
rights of those who are registered as
foreign agents
there were no rights violations at all
in that regard
would you like to hear the um breakdown
by the party because we have a lot of
data here
let's take a look at that
i'm not sure if this is the total or the
breakdown
what we have here is
speaking about the single sid
constituencies
we have six
116 048
we have
627 from the political parties and from
the non-governmental organizations 169
people
from the
public oversight
uh we have
and 344
344 were observers from the public
oversight organizations as for the
parties uh 990
1919 were the observers from the united
russia
in total that's about 120 000 people
in the communist party provided about 50
observers against the 300 000 they were
announcing before the election
uh the party of the retired people
23 000 observers new people
uh provided 15 000 observers liberal
democrats provided about 13 000
observers
i think
yes
yeah you're getting it correctly
uh this civic platform provided 7500
observers
the party wrote in uh 600 and 500.
um
the green alternative provided
about 6 000 observers at the party of
growth provided
about 400 and 600 observers and the
green party uh 1020 2200 people
and yeah
they provided
771 observer
but
that's
but they uh yeah in total they managed
to provide three hundred and
three thousand and six hundred observers
and just russia
provided
85 observers and 21 observers were from
the
election commission that's the
preliminary data i'm sharing with you
so
what
what were the challenges this time we
had unprecedented cyber attacks against
our website all our
resources and i think our specialist
will share these data
we
have
mr masoch here and we have summed up our
results already we had we summed up the
results or the online vote and we
saw that unfortunately moscow was late
with reporting its result on the online
vote we will have moscow
and we will hear from moscow and we will
hear from the federal center for
information
for the first time in many years we've
faced some
technical challenges and nuances
these are mostly related and it is
very interesting and
very good that we have withstood all
these cyber attacks
but the fact that we've faced this
unprecedented attack is a fact
so
please uh
so we
had
the results in gas elections system
all the protocols are related to
the
[Music]
online vote and they were all recorded
by the territorial election commissions
this means that today
regarding the
problems with all the reporting on
online voting we have no such problems
everything was properly
recorded including both the party lists
and the candidate list so this is a fact
and
please keep this in mind thank you so
much mr bulaiv
it is too early to congratulate anyone
until
we
sum up all the results all the final
results on friday this will be the time
for thanking everyone but we have a very
busy week ahead of us and i wanted to
share with you
about the online vote uh and like please
keep up this discussion i unfortunately
have
to leave you
[Music]
so thank you so much miss bonfila oh
good afternoon to all of
you
so the territorial commission
worked
on the online vote in the sixth region
in the murmurs region yaroslav region
kursk region nizhny novgorod region rust
of region the city of
sevastopol and moscow
so
everything worked fine
it was business as usual for us we
assembled the encryption key yesterday
and the very procedure
to lift the encryption took about
30 minutes
and after that
the commission got down to its work it
was just
business as usual just like any election
commission works in the near region we
had the protocol we signed the protocol
but
the only difference was that we signed
it electronically
and
in fact
it
was much easier than signing it
by hand by 11
all of the formalities all the
technicalities were completed by 12
by midnight
we had
all the results that were uploaded to
the gas election system all these
protocols are now publicly available
on the relevant website
so everything worked as it was supposed
to
regarding the six regions
that
held the online vote
and
there were some applications from
citizens to the commission in total
about 15
applications from citizens
all of these applications were related
to technical matters
there was not a single complaint no
single application can be viewed as a
complaint so
union so there was a decision unanimous
decision by the commission to sign the
protocol there was a dissenting opinion
by one of the members but everything was
very public
and open and transparent and we
presented all this information on the
relevant website
thank you so much for this report i
would like to thank the territorial
commission for the
online vote this was a very important
work we were
of course
really anxious about on how this
election will go
so how
everything happened
and how the vote was held
in moscow
within the uh system we have
yuri ermolfo
so
we will have a comment from moscow
good afternoon colleagues
the
commissions that
worked in moscow on the online vote was
where some with
from the federal level we
have election commission for every
electoral district
and the central election commission
authorized us and we
used this right
to
share the responsibility between and to
shift it between various districts for
the
state domain election we have 15
electoral districts
so we had 15
districts
and we summed up the results for 15
districts but only one district election
commission had the authority
to sum up the results
the same applies to the additional
election to the moscow city duma we had
two districts but only one district
election commission for the online vote
had the
authority and it was vested with the
authority of the second commission
the
third subject is
about the municipal election
there were five
single-seat constituencies we had five
districts and
only one commission had all the
authority
and
the second difference is the fact that
we use the
moscow a special platform that was
developed by moscow and for moscow to
accept applications
from those who wanted to vote in the
election and those who voted
so my colleague here is one of the
developers of this system and i would
like to pass him the floor
yes thank you so much
a very good afternoon to all of you
so everything worked out fine during the
election we had minor
issues since a lot of people were
willing to vote during the first day
and people who saw the online queue so
there was some confusion at the
beginning people had to wait a little
bit but then they were let in they could
wait all the votes were encrypted all
these data are now publicly available
all the encryption keys
are there and
we can certify the accuracy of of all
these data
when
we
use the encryption
key we had a delay because
we had a lot of transactions that we had
to process um this is the first time
that we're holding such a large-scale
election using this system at all the
levels at the regional and federal and
municipal levels so there were a lot of
transactions a lot of ballots were cast
electronically and it took some time to
prepare the protocols and to upload them
to the national election system gas
elections so it took some time
thank you i would like to remind you
colleagues that
the
protocols
were provided from all
the
district election commission
and for all the territorial commissions
we
included these protocols into the
protocols of the relevant six regions
that held online votes so this was quite
a challenging task
and
moscow has been holding this
experiment for two years to hold
online elections overall
the moscow election commission and the
moscow government they deserve a special
gratitude
for the work that they have done
at
the
digital
polling stations and it enabled us to
test the online voting system
so if there will be questions we will go
back to you
we'll go back to moscow and please
good afternoon
thank you for giving me the floor i
would like to begin by reporting
that
gas elections during the entire campaign
it performed its mission
there were some hiccups there were some
issues that we addressed in a timely
manner i would like to
briefly say a few words
about how the system work and how
the
central election commission website
worked during the campaign and the
election
during the 17 to 19 september 2021
apart from the election to the state
duma during this day of the election we
had
a number of election campaigns that were
carried out across the country i do not
remember a single voting day
i do not remember a single day when
during a single day
there was
a federal campaign a federal election to
the stadium
39 elections to
regional legislative assemblies nine
campaigns to elect regional heads
and about 4 000 election campaigns to
elect
officials in municipalities and villages
and other settlements so this was an
unprecedented number of campaigns an
unprecedented number of protocols to
fill out
so a huge burden something really that
we have never seen before
and in addition to this we had quite a
few protocols i will cite some numbers
maybe you have heard them already
well we have been uh
seeing how these results were uploaded
to gas election system we had about 350
000 protocols on election results
so
this is an unprecedented workload but
you can see the numbers
that all these
data were properly
handled and in a good time every
protocol every report takes about one
second to process or even less
so there were no problems with
processing protocols there is no such
problem
and i would like to draw your attention
to the fact that
usually
96 to 97
of the protocols
are collected by 10 or 11 a.m on monday
but on these days it turned out that
it's now 3 p.m but we're at 98 percent
at on our counter
so
considering the number of protocols that
we have this is what we have um
well
we have a report here with all the
numbers what i wanted to say
is that before we got the report
uh the members of the election
commission
uh produce it they do a lot of work it's
extensive work
now they enter the data into the
software system
and it's a huge load
workload
i'll just give you some numbers as an
example
for example in each uh
each commission
uh gets
and 2606
produce seven protocols and a thousand
and seventy eight commissions produce
more
that's a record-setting number of
protocols
produced by a single uh commission
during the selection there was online
voting option
that's new
and what what is new about it
um there were
there were different numbers ballots for
each vote
from two to five
uh that was also had to be you know set
up correctly in the system
um as a result of the online vote
uh we're getting results from the moscow
election committee well you just heard
the report
i think
that
both sides
the organizers and the observers and the
voters
might have had difficulty figuring out
what's
where and how it works
speaking of the online
voting
because for instance election city
election had its own online platform
uh in moscow
and the um
[Music]
structure of the election committees in
moscow it also differs from that uh
in other regions of russia so there were
you know discrepancies
um
all this has to be taken into account
in terms of time
that is required to calculate the final
votes
[Music]
so in case of
any mismatches
or discrepancies all the commissions
had to
deal with those
that was new um you know because of the
online system
and they had to react according to the
law to apply the law to the new system
that also required you know more effort
than uh
could have been expected
uh also there were um anti-pandemic
measures
in place in all the polling stations
so
there was a social distancing um
requirement implemented everywhere
there were stations with a high turnout
that in those it was particularly
important
um
they were um
there was equipment
for disinfecting the ballots
installed in such stations
we did not have
legislation that stipulates exactly how
it should be done but we've been doing
our best
um
well you know there are polling boxes
and all that
standard voting equipment that had to be
processed
it was taking more time than we did
expect
i
wanted to say a few words about the
central election committee online portal
website
[Music]
well speaking of the porto i just would
like to say a few words so that you
would understand
how it works what it's like
so both the federal center and the
central election committee
the requirement is for these two parties
two bodies to maintain the portal
running and to
provide the voters with the opportunity
to vote
and to
our online portal was developed in 2001
so since today is 2021 it was a while
ago 20 years ago
[Music]
well it was updated in
2010 and uh well we added more functions
there was a good upgrade
and the number of visitors to the portal
has been growing ever since
and uh
well we've we had a number of
breakthroughs in the uh into i.t
technology area
and also applied eti technology
you know people now use gadgets mobile
devices
and
you see it every it's part of our
everyday life right now
that's the reality and we need to take
it into account
uh but due to this the number of cyber
threats has been increasing
and our duty is to guarantee the access
of the voters to our website
despite that threat
so
i would like to say that especially to
the mass media representatives present
here
that according to the federal law of the
russian federation
[Music]
access
to the data
about the preliminary and final results
is the requirement of the law
the voters should be able to read
such data off the website
the methods that we use
you know the number of bots and all such
tools and devices that we have now in
the world is unprecedented even two to
three four years ago we never faced
problems of such a scale as today so you
see as the portal was upgraded back in
2010 uh that upgrade of pos could not
possibly withstand the scope of the
threats we're dealing with now
so in order to
for the website to maintain its work
we made the decision
to
impose
limitations
on the automated tools for data
collection
so
some of the federal law articles allowed
for that
the articles that stipulate requirements
to the websites of the federal bodies of
the russian federation so that decision
was made
and um
last year if you remember then there was
a
single vote day
a lot of uh it was debate debated a lot
and
we
decided well based on that experience
that since it was not very user-friendly
that approach that was used last year
we reconsidered how the access could be
granted to
uh
average user in good
conscience so we developed the
requirements
to the software that
provides
for the uh
online portal accessibility
so that accounts for security
and some limitations
foreign
europe
[Music]
um
foreign
yes
m
foreign
on